Hi. Welcome back to town of Salem with the gang
this is the coven update including 15 new roles, a bunch of new game modes and
A coven only queue. Check it out on steam!
Wade: I don't have hair (???)
Bob:You're so ugly, you deserve to die
*elevator music*
*more elevator music*
Jack: Basically what he said, so yeah?
Wade: I mean being irrelevant and being lined up for death, I think are two different things?
Mark: no no no no no no no no no
Jack: How dare you stand here and make a ways
Bob: No, no, no no
Mark: Wade, Are you out of your gourd?
Bob: He's got a gourd?
Jack: He's fucking tree
mark: *giggles*
wade: Guys, please I don't think that death is a-
mark: get the fuck back in your gourd dude
bob: *laughs*
bob: Yeah, I did not type tarnation
mark: oh Yeah, I think anal- anal turns to pillion or something like that. pillion.  yeah.
jack: wha-ha-at?
mark: anal turns to pillion
wade: bob, stop giving me away
jack: ummmm........
*bob and wade laughing evilly*
wade: tits or gtfo
bob: tits or gtfo *laughs*
jack: WHAT ARE THE ROLES? BRING IT ON DOWN
mark: uuuh
bob: YEEHEHEHEHEHEH
mark: WHAT IS THAT THING?
jack: OOOOH BOYYYY
mark: i dont know what that is?
mark: oooh..........
wade: let's see what happens!
mark: kill me is- fuck me
mark: kill me and fuck me
bob: that censor really fucks up because i typed "kill me"
i guess, fuck me, and it totally ruined both of those words
Wade: I guess we knew-
jack: YOU'RE DEAD
wade: -what that words are for those who are left
jack: it was tiny
tiny and tits
ahh there we go
bob: poor d-life
mark: this is so sad, fuck fuck fuck
J: I like it, but this one is mine. Well my well. I'm nothing let me my will is nothing
Wade: Come on, I typed 'tits'
Bob: I was the spy. I not lie. Town is just asshole.
Mark: So you're all dead yeah alright, so I'm the escort who should I distract?
Tonight at tit tits real failure time probably all right well I would like escort
Hit big titties ya- here's some tits mmM gotcha
Jack: nailed it
Mark: Yeah, I did that Jack: yeah you're a good escort boy
Thank you when youtube fails me because the paul bros. Takes over YouTube because you know it will
Every day. Oh my God good. God the fuck happened. Oh
Yeah, yeah smelly now
This is big of Rigsy coven verses to killing their go to bear meat
Incinerated by an arsonist their pSychic. What does the pSychic actually do call it beams guys horribly ah?
Yeah, I distracted titties. They're dead chat believes in you
Lord so she must have shit, what the fuck?
0 1 0 0 1 0 0 1 0 0 1 month is at the time code yeah
Well to tell one great. That's good. Happy smile always friend. You're the line Tony
Good luck Morgan. I got it. You can love our arsonist at a hex master. What anybody for a good, hahaha
Big Giant Also a Mark Giant Prostitutes Dana
Don't worry about Lois facial expression - he's just constantly just like
And weights this behind him like oh, yay. Get it daddy, sit on me, Santa Daddy
Well sex is just flashing over there crush me with your giant Santa thighs
I'd like to have a connection
I don't know what to say no one's going up there. No one can vote. I don't know why they're not voting for you
They can just fucking end this right now. Yeah, they are the town which one of them should I distract tiny or sexy I?
Know it's one
Okay, so well go all out with a nice bag. Oh, I'm on going sick. Yeah. That's why I got a good
Pattern here in the other game the earlier game. We played. We were we were mostly coven and coven lost in this game
We were all
Jaha
Fuck even though we started the rAbbi killing people to come in
Yeah
the crew second
Yeah, we go the same way
I was what are the procedures even do we protect or money somebody visits then we kill them?
I think they're dragging this out. Yeah new balls. Give me a decimal
let me know your house is happy Valentine's day light flashing so I'm going to
Come into Valentine's hours. I show you good time with my man yet
My dominion can you know?
Hi
based on backups wrong way very Russian I
Don't know I have your ass short plan here. Do you want Papers or are?
Bahahaha I
Got to you with my giant cock oh
Funny story my right arm is actually really fucked up. They felt that of where my penis used to be oh
Ha ha why are we voting tiny like?
Sure, sure let's go with this one cares. Is that the arsonist is sexy Gonna now try and kill you?
Infinite loop. Can you just distract them everybody maybe yeah? You don't have a limited number of distractions, right?
You can bone every night all night. Hahaha. Come to born palace. Hey, sexy. You want again, okay?
hahaha
A different escort is you know this is you?
know back
- Keepers, I
Don't understand. What are you guys going to Santa? Oh no man, no?
24 Century Russia or something I knew
Santa was Paul brothers
Everyday, bro. Oh
Why are you worried April? This is oh?
Yeah
Looks like I got visited right away anyway, so I would be dead from the arsons, but I didn't die from the crusader
looks like epoch
Looks like I'm going to have another fun
Out of this, I don't know deliver all of your presence
I'm going to deliver millions of presents
Huh, huh, huh? Huh? Huh? Huh? Hey
Rose
Santa comes down your chimney delivery across the lines yeah, and that was not okay, what the hell man?
Santa Don't Care Santa
you
another beautiful day
Thank you friend. How many turns does it take to draw it today keep going?
Oh, if you could indicate a russian accent when you typed I wish there was a symbol for this backwards R's
In what you're typing just for random backwards R's unrelated to the actual cyrillic characters just like this
It's russian pillow says happy smiles kind of annoying
Well now you're a frog great the fuck do we do. I'm still the truth. I let you cheat
Why are they both Russian Russian who acted funny?
Watching you look I don't like some more today ger hybrid
s sound like Schwarzenegger
Get in the chopper
Look Aa russian either. I think maybe pushing pencils
Jews so would you guys got me back give up or something or you know don't about school yourself
Okay, I'm into submission Madam. I need to submit
That's course sexy I did
Give up give up. Oh we wouldn't just
Lead lead tomorrow with I will not stop tarnation in you until you let me win. It happens
one stagnation
Without turning you into a frog. Oh look a lot of hobbiton
okay, maybe next time were you believe a
never-ending game can can I
It's by pushing the girl
Just wait just roll them into leaving that's how you win. Oh the great of times
I don't know what I've ever seen a draw in this game
It's gotta at some point
It's got to just cut off returns or something when it when they realize that it's a draw
But apparently not they didn't plan in the coven expansion for this to happen
Wait, no the escort wasn't me escort like a basic one. Yeah, yeah escorts a regular role
Yeah, can you vote for him not to vote you needed?
Shit vote for yourself though for yourself. I can't
Sooner or later. Oh wait so on things that Santa might be poisoned already good
Doesn't would I know that or would I not know that? I don't know I didn't notice that I was
You don't get to know when you're like doused or poisoned or anything anymore? That's a
Bell you know if you need you need to offer people. I believe a so much here
So don't be press that window
She'll be picked up a moose. It's working every time. I shall be myself billion
You want you want you want wild ride they can't be pissed drop in mentos, and then shove up ass
Crazy Throw and a Pro
Fuck somebody high got it
They say the big brother only mark would die and it would tell him if he did oh no make my money in
seven never died in the supply
Good job Mars review threw it out. It's gonna be you and butterflies fucking forever. I'm tired to tarnation you each night. What the hell?
Every night when sun go down the blackout. I wake up to you next morning in bed
Totally satisfied simply by all Salem white at this root Key Key Key Key Key Key Every day
Every Day Christmas it wait
Belle isn't one of us is it is that one of us usually when he can have crackle pop and Iris tarnation?
I was Alice young
Lapel is actually just awesome. Well one mutual admiration
I like the way to heaven so you guys had gone on during the day there. Yeah, good stuff. Good stuff
this isn't a
Quality content yeah, golly I was stimulating does elf. I'm sorry you guys are so bored. I
Died thank you for today
It's been a long time since I've had direction of blood you've had platoon. Oh vente get more
364 days no action save up for one night. I think this is a good episode. Oh
Okay, so to draw yeah draw yeah
nobody wins and yeah
hahahahaha boner dern sticker
*Laughter from all*
J: Crazy cumudegeon *russian accent*
W: I wondered why you typed cumudgeon *laughter still* *outro music*
*Laughter*
M: Oh fuck
[OUTRO]